Is your wife disciplined?
How do you navigate a potential mismatch between you two?
What about when family,
non disciplined costs you unexpected time and energy taking from your goals?
Family nondisciplinary what?
Like my family's not being disciplined,
not on board or whatever.
They're not on board with the program.
My wife is,
she runs a tight ship and as disciplined in a little bit of a different way than
me.
Uh,
then she's not the same as me.
And if that were to cause some kind of a conflict between us,
well then that's my fault for not communicating with her and allowing her to
understand my perspective and understanding her perspective.
So for instance,
what are,
what's the situation,
right?
Oh,
my wife wants me,
you know,
she wants to spend time with me in the morning,
whatever.
Right?
What did you wake up early and work out before she's awake?
You're working out.
It's not her fault.
It's my fault.
Well,
what about when,
oh,
I really want to eat dinner with you at night.
Okay,
cool.
I'll eat dinner with you and I'll stay up later at night.
So that I can get my work done and that's fine.
You go to bed,
that's not,
that's not my responsibility.
That's not your responsibility.
That's my responsibility.
It's not your responsibility to mold your life around my whole life.
Right.
That's not,
that's,
that's not the way it is.
And by the way,
when the family is doing something that is taken away,
what did he say?
My energy taken away my energy and taking away my time.
Then I fixed that problem and when I say that I fixed the problem,
I don't mean I fix them do,
I don't mean that I impose my discipline on them.
I'm,
it might involve some adjustments or some attempts to get adjustments,
but I'm not,
be this really simple.
I don't blame my family when things don't go right.
I couldn't work out today because my kid was sick.
My daughter spilled the milk and I was like,
Hey,
this is the same.
This is just about ownership.
Like if you just want to blame your family when you're weak or you make a
mistake or you didn't organize or you didn't explain to people correctly,
then that's the way it is.
I can say this to your family is not you.
Your family is not you.
They aren't on your program.
That's not there.
That's not their deal.
Hey,
if they're on it,
great.
That's cool.
My family is not all on my program.
That's not the way it works in impose.
Oh,
that's fun.
There wasn't,
where's that gets you?
You,
Oh,
you want to,
you want to impose your program on everyone in your family.
What are they going to do?
What?
It's the same thing that happens with any team.
If you start imposing your strict discipline on them,
cool.
You can get them to do what you want them to do at that moment.
Guess what they do?
As soon as they get the opportunity to rebel against you,
they rebel.
You get a mutiny.
You get a kid that's rebellious beyond the norm that's doing thing that's
actually gonna going to really reject you.
So you got to,
you've don't blame your family.
Fix the problem.
Do you know who you have control over?
You?
You don't have control.
You don't have control over your nine year old kid.
You might think you do,
but you don't.
You've got to make,
you don't have control over your wife to just make her,
you know,
get in the game.
Oh,
you want to,
you want to stay on the program,
you want to cook,
uh,
whatever.
14 chicken breasts on a Sunday night.
So you've got two a day during the week,
honey,
make it happen.
No honey,
no.
Make that happen.
If you are a good leader and you explain what your goals are and you get her on
board with the program,
then yeah,
guess what she's doing on Sunday night helping you cook some chicken breasts for
the week.
Yeah,
but this is just like anything else,
man.
This is just like any other leadership situation.
You want to blame the team when something's going wrong that's not going to get
you a solution.
You need to take ownership of the problem.
You need to get the problem solved.
And when I say get the problem solved you,
this doesn't mean impose your will on the team.
That means you need to lead the team and there's a big difference.
So
get some,
yeah.
Yeah.
And by the way,
the better,
just like anything else,
just like Hackworth,
the better relationship that you build with your wife and with your kids,
guess what?
The more flexibility you have,
the more the leeway they give you.
The worst relationship you build with your wife and kids,
the less flexible and the less leeway and the less chicken breasts you're going
to have cook for you.
It's true.
They're not in the game with you.
Yeah.
So build a relationship.
I know that might sound like like,
oh,
well we're married so we have relationships.
Not necessarily true.
Yeah.
Build a relationship.
Make them understand where you're coming from.
Make them understand what the strategic goals are.
Yeah.
Make them understand.
Just like in a leadership situation,
make sure they understand how the strategic goals that you're trying to achieve
for yourself.
We'll then come all the way back down and impact them in a positive way.
Because by the way,
if you're doing things strategically that are gonna help you,
that are going to screw over the rest of the team,
or in this case family,
guess what?
You're not going to get support for those goals because they're not helping out
the team.
If you're doing it for yourself and yourself only that's problematic.
Yeah.
So if you're,
hey,
I want to work out,
I want to get,
you know,
I want to work out,
I want to train Jujitsu every day.
Okay,
well how do I benefit from that?
Yeah,
honey,
how does,
yeah.
Okay,
well let me tell you how.
Here's my plan.
In six years,
I,
you know,
I'm a purple belt right now it's six years.
I'm going to get my black belt and when I get my black belt,
we're going to open a school and when I open a school,
guess what we're going to do all day?
We're going to teach Jujitsu,
we're going to hang out at our gym.
We're going to have a good time.
That's the strategic goal.
I need you in the game with me right now.
That's totally different than war trued.
Yup.
I'm a man.
Yeah.
They'll keep me,
keep me from this.
Well,
yeah,
in that,
depending on who you are,
obviously,
but I would even say that's,
even speaking from my own experience,
that's even over saying it really,
like let's say take Jujitsu or working out or whatever.
Yeah.
You know,
like to,
you know,
to do that.
But I get,
I get the example for sure.
No,
you're gonna say something much more simple,
easier way more bay and just say,
Hey,
this,
this part of my life.
Even if it's new,
it's a new,
I know our family's chaotic.
You need my help with the kids and be like,
but hey,
this,
this is sort of,
this means a lot to me and it makes me feel good.
Makes me,
you know,
a happy person or whatever.
It can mean you can,
we make this work,
you know,
Ken,
can we do,
what do you want from me?
You know how you like this other thing.
Sure.
Yeah.
I want to support you doing that.
Here's where I need support,
right?
Yes.
Thing puts a smile on my face.
Yeah.
You want me smiling around here?
That's what,
and people,
I'm sure someone's going to bring up the fact that there were times when I was
in the ames and I would come home from work at seven 30 at night.
I'd pick up my gym bag,
a dropoff,
my my work bag,
and I just walked.
I'd go,
Oh,
hang on,
I'm going to train.
And there was a few times where she did not want me to go train tears in her
eyes.
You got to be kidding me.
You've been gone all week.
You've been gone for two weeks.
You come home at seven 30 and you're going to go train instead of eating dinner
with us.
I was like,
Yep,
that the reason I bring that up,
because I know someone's gonna break up.
That's not good leadership.
That's not me being cool.
That's not me building the relationship.
That's me moving in the other direction.
Yeah.
So that's not what I'm saying to do,
but if you come home,
hey look,
here's the deal.
Here's what's going on.
Here's why I,
you know what I've got,
I come home from work.
I got a lot of stuff on my brain.
I'm in a bad mood when I come home and I don't want to be in a bad mood around,
you don't want to be a bad mood around the kids.
I'm going to go train for an hour.
When I come back I'm going to have a smile on my face.
Watch
what?
Boom.
And man like and,
and that's actually my wife eventually told me like,
oh,
when you don't train,
you're not nice to be around.
Not that I was intentionally [inaudible] no,
but you just have the,
uh,
you don't,
you don't have that release that that is a real thing for sure.
I mean it's manageable.
Everyone's different I think,
obviously,
but I wouldn't,
you can even say something even more sick cause that's a hard one to,
to sell sometimes to some people to be like,
hey,
all be happier,
you know?
Yeah.
Then they'll be like,
mm,
well or except for that all be happier.
Mains,
we'll be happier.
Yeah.
And you've got to,
you're right though,
you got a bar,
you've got to give and take.
Right.
You've got to say,
okay,
what do you,
what can I do for you?
Exactly.
Right.
That's,
that's what it is.
Be like,
Hey,
this means a lot to me.
You know,
to,
and usually,
you know,
in a relationship like that,
they care if something means something to your husband and wife or whatever.
Like that's not nothing.
That's something,
you know,
look,
if you,
if the,
if you're a husband and you say this did you use,
it means a lot to me.
Therefore you need to sacrifice your whole thing to accommodate it.
You can't do that.
But it's not nothing.
So you should say,
hey,
as a leader you can't have the team sacrifice everything thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
I do a good job on this mission.
I'm going to get promoted,
you know,
or hey,
if we do a good job with this product,
I'm going to make more money.
It's more from my bottom line profitability for our shareholders.
No one cares.
The front line doesn't care about profitability for the shareholders unless they
understand how it relates back to them.
Yeah.
So family doesn't care about you train in Jujitsu unless they realize how it's
going to come back to you.
So what you do is you tell her like,
hey,
just can we make this work and actually whatever,
however this gets in the way of us,
you know,
like whatever.
Like I want to just in general make that up to some way,
you know,
like what can,
what can I do for you?
Like I said,
or,
or what do you want to do something or I could list,
let's do this so we can both kind of have something fun.
Come with me if you want,
but hey,
I don't,
don't,
don't just automatically expect your wife to love Jujitsu like you love to do
too.
Unfortunately,
unfortunately.
Goes for everyone almost.
It's possible.
Very possible.
Yeah.
But I'm saying,
you know,
if like how you're saying like make it make,
you got to accommodate it,
you know,
straight.
If you're doing like a workout,
let's say,
and it's your thing,
right?
Like to look,
don't work out and you know,
and that's my thing.
Whatever.
Jujitsu I think is a different one because working out is like,
you can kind of do that whenever.
Yeah.
But Jujitsu is like,
if you don't be,
you got to go train with some people.
Yeah.
You know?
So yeah man,
if,
and constant communication too by the way,
like you know,
cause after a while it's like,
oh you're going to use it again.
They're like done.
Or the kids kind of need help with the homework and I'm swamped with this other
family stuff,
you know,
kind of thing.
But if you're constantly communicating and then she'll tell you,
hey,
do you mind not going on this day because of this?
And you're like,
okay,
me going on this specific day,
is that more important than the help that they need with the homework,
you know?
And you can accurately kind of navigate your way through your,
your new situation,
you know?
But yeah,
you gotta keep talking on that one because some people they think,
oh,
I can go,
do you get to know?
And I don't have to say nothing.
I'm on.
I'm just rolling out under every circle.
You know?
It doesn't work like that sometimes.
Don't,
don't be like me in that sense.
Don't be like Taco.
You probably,
my wife was very understanding.
Yeah,
so that's great.
Yeah.
My wife probably would have murdered me,
rightfully so,
like killed me like as a crime.